roll sound roll camera ready boys why
please we're west scene 12 take one you
feel about the size of the audiences
I've been a little disappointed and they
said could you persuade stan and Ollie
to do some publicity in order to turn a
tour around it'll be any more money they
said no but who is they people the worst
kind here we are the Eiffel Tower house
you need have hurts is even pushing you
a little to armaid know if it a long
time ago so goodbye Oliver that's all in
the past you know still carrying that
around are you because I went ahead and
did a picture with someone else 16 years
ago
you and Harry are just gonna be great
together couldn't sleep the days when
they told me what you did and I couldn't
sleep when I did it you betrayed me
betrayed our friendship
I loved us and you loved Laurel and
Hardy but you never loved me
[Music]
the doctors told me I can't continue
with the tour my heart won't take it
he asked me since he was sick if I
wouldn't mind carrying on the show with
somebody else
they introduced to mr. Bobby Cook you're
not leaving are you Stan the show must
go on that was
pure magic it's brilliant
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
we like to finish now with a little -
sure I can
I'll miss us when we're gone so we
[Music]
[Applause]
what time is it now hold this
do we really need that trunk
[Music]
you